so i didn't know that you
are a concealed gun carry instructor
yeah casio carrier so official certified
uscca and nra concealed carry instructor
yeah and you started a new gun safety
company called the gun camp
yeah this is in chicago yeah so
i'm a because i'm i'm a proponent i'm a
pretty liberal dude but i'm very
very you know i feel like we should all
have a right to protect ourselves
what i'm saying um well how did you get
involved in
in that because i would never in my
wildest dreams picture
you know man like i've always been into
firearms but then when i got my
concealed carry my boy
eddie trained me uh to get my concealed
carry license
and then when i wanted to be an
instructor my boy creative can train me
my creative trained me to be a concealed
carry instructor
really during that whole quarantine
you know so i think a lot of us got an
extra career in the quarantine around
that quarantine thing so
you know what happened with with me was
i got into
that whole industry very heavy you know
and became an instructor and just
you know just been going after a lot of
certification since then
a few extra ones you know so um that's
something i'm into
heavy i'm an advocate for um second
amendment
yeah definitely i want to i want to
teach people the right way
when it comes to course guns and gun
safety and
yeah you know just the people's thought
process about guns
yeah i think that um sometimes in
hip-hop we get like a little like
wrapped up in like uh
whatever the popular issue is at the
time
and and you know i always talk with
killer mike about this because killer
mike's also a very
pro second amendment he's gotten a lot
of [ __ ] for that by the way like
they came came for him a lot but i think
that uh
you know especially in l.a it's crazy
no they've came for mike a lot yeah i
know that and it's it's wild
it's like it doesn't make any sense and
you know i think that um
he would always say like our our people
more than anybody
we need to protect ourselves more than
anybody you know what i'm saying
especially what's been going on in the
world the last you know with this trump
[ __ ] and all this other wild [ __ ] like
you never know
but it's never know what can happen but
like we live in like i live in
california and it's like out here they
pretty much make it
as impossible as possible for you to
protect yourself
so it's like out here [ __ ] is
getting robbed
shit's i'm from phoenix though
phoenix is anybody can have a gun
yeah but you can't have a negligent
discharge in phoenix it's rough ain't it
right what you mean i think in uh
arizona if you
you have a negligent discharge it's a
little rough you just fire the gun
with that yeah with that type of law i
just know that a mistake like that i
know there
like i could literally give you my gun
and that's your it's your gun now
you don't have to worry about
registering it you don't you mean like
cass is really it's the wild wild west
in chicago no i'm sure i'm sure right
two cards well i was gonna say there's
got this it's like two sides of the coin
because if we think of chicago and the
gun violence in chicago right
like you know obviously
people are going to get guns no matter
what right yeah that that pretty much
says it like like no matter how the gun
laws are different
in each state you still got violence
yeah and the people who are
who want those guns who are committing
those crimes they're going to get those
guns
i don't get them no matter what so why
not be protected
like why not be protected legally
obviously you know what i'm saying
what they say uh the only thing that
stops a bad guy with a gun
is a good guy with a gun ain't that the
truth ain't that the truth
yeah it's a very it's just i just think
you know it's interesting like i think
more more people like yourself and mike
should like you know
i think it's dope that you guys talk
about that because in hip hop you know
and i'm a like i said i'm pretty much
liberal on
most things just the gun [ __ ] i'm like
listen man like
this was america for a reason yeah yeah
you know it's in the it's in the
constitution that we could protect
ourselves
yeah you know what i mean and it is what
it is and you know
a lot of times we we you know we are
conditioned
to have a perception of guns that make
you go oh
you know what everybody else going
so your your thing is is to try to just
educate people like yo
like this is you know because because
gun's a scary thing you know what i'm
saying so
when you do these courses you're
teaching people about the weapon you're
teaching people how to
take it apart put it like like what are
you teaching people yeah we're teaching
all of that we're teaching people how to
break a gun down put it back together
like you know
a field strip so you can clean it and
everything the parts to a gun
how to hold the gun proper stance proper
grip
the uh safety rules you know how to keep
your finger off the trigger
you know how to make sure you don't
muzzle anybody the whole
everything so so not only just the
mentality of having a gun but how to
properly
uh care for a gun and handle it with
safety